منافسات المخ تقليد باكستاني غائر في
القدم وحدث قروي وشعبي في ليالي شهر رمضان
المبارك فبعد يوم من الصيام والصلاه يجتمع
سكان العديد من القرى في باكستان لقضاء
امسيات رمضان بطريقتهم الخاصه هنا يتنافس
رومات من مختلف القرى في اصابه هدف صيني
تباعا لتحقيق اعلى نسبه اصابه من اجل
الفوز
شاركت في صغري في العديد من المنافسات فزت
وخسرت هذه اللعبه هي عاده بشتونيه تقام في
شهر رمضان بعد صلاه التراويح وتستمر حتى
وقت السحور وتعود جذورها الى النبي
ابراهيم الخليل مرورا بالتراث الاسلامي
تسود لحظات من الصمت والترقب ويحدث
المشجعون انفاسهم كلما هم اللاعبون او
الرومات في اطلاق سهامهم ثم تتعالى اصوات
البهجه المشجعين باصابه الهدف
والتاهل الى جوله جديده
قواعد لعبه المخا بسيطه لكنها تتطلب قوه
ومهاره وتركيزا من قبل اللاعبين
وصلنا الى دور النصف نهائي على كل لاعب
اطلاق السهم مرتين في كل جوله وحاليا
فريقنا متقدم بنقطتين نامل ان نفوز اليوم
ونتاهل الى الدوري النهائي
منافسه رمضان اقصائيه حيث يتاهل الفريق
الفائز للجوله التاليه ويخرج الخاصل من
المنافسه فورا يتم احتساب النقاط باكثر
عدد لاصابه الهدف
يصنع رمح المخ من خيزران خاص يؤتى به من
كشمير يصل طوله الى ثمان اقدام وله راس
حديدي محدد اما الهدف فهو لوح صيني يتم
ترميمه بعد كل اصابه ادوات ولعبه ان بدت
بسيطه انها تجمع بين الترفيه والمنافسه
والترابط الاجتماعي الذي يتجلى في ابهى
صوره في شهر رمضان الكريم
لعبه شعبيه متوارثه في باكستان لا تزال
تحافظ على ارقها وخصوصيتها في ليالي شهر
رمضان المبارك عبد الرحمن المزيني العربيه
اقليم خيبر بخوان